un centenar de metros apenas separan a
china continental de hong kong o de un
lado y del otro hay rejas familias y
amigos se dan cita aquí para verse
durante unos instantes
[Música]
algunos no han vuelto a verse desde hace
años desde el inicio de la pandemia y el
cierre de las fronteras este habitante
de hong kong no sabe cuándo podrá
reunirse con su esposa y su hijo del
otro lado
[Música]
él trabaja en schengen del lado chino
pero su familia vive en hong kong antes
de la pandemia podía atravesar la
frontera todas las semanas actualmente
está bloqueado aquí
hacemos videollamadas pero eso no es
nada comparado con el hecho de verlos en
persona hace mucho que estoy lejos de mi
familia me hacen falta
para ingresar a chinas son necesarias
tres semanas de cuarentena por unos mil
euros a cargo del viajero imposible para
este cuadragenario hacer esas idas y
venidas un suplicio necesario según él
hay que hacerlo es por el mundo entero
por nosotros y por el país estoy de
acuerdo con estas medidas sólo hay que
sacrificarnos un poco china hace muchos
sacrificios en nombre de su política
acero kobe aquí no se concibe convivir
con el virus y funciona oficialmente del
país cuenta con menos de seis mil
muertos desde el principio de la
pandemia en cuanto hay un caso positivo
las autoridades hacen pruebas confinan
le hacen seguimiento a la más mínima
amenaza en la ciudad de chengdu los
cavas sus contactos son ubicados gracias
a sus teléfonos mediante la supervisión
de los datos de ubicación basta con
estar durante 10 minutos a menos de 800
metros de una persona positiva para ser
enviado a cuarentena en noviembre debido
a una decena de casos de kobe 82 mil
personas se volvieron sospechosas
pruebas masivas y cuarentenas
obligatorias medidas aprobadas por los
habitantes
estas medidas eran indispensables porque
todas las vidas son valiosas y deben ser
protegidas fue complicado mi barrio
estaba bloqueado pero no hay opciones
a mí me parece que era garantizar la
seguridad de todos e impedir que el
virus se dispersa fue eficaz
esta eficacia implacable tiene un precio
la parálisis
tal como en chillán en el norte del país
por 200 casos al 23 de diciembre 13
millones de habitantes están confinados
hasta nueva orden la ciudad entera fue
desinfectada salvo para ir a hacerse una
prueba está prohibido poner un pie
afuera incluso para hacer compras de
alimentos en las redes sociales algunos
habitantes piden ayuda
[Música]
la lucha contra el kobe 19 es una
prioridad absoluta incluso con métodos
extremos como la humillación pública
estos cuatro hombres son acusados de
haber ayudado a extranjeros a cruzar la
frontera entre vietnam y china la
policía local hace desfilar sus fotos
con sus nombres como ejemplo este
paredón de la vergüenza ha sido
criticado por algunos medios oficiales e
internautas las críticas contra la
política de 'cero cobit son raras
incluso si estas medidas draconianas
podrían hacer perder hasta un punto de
crecimiento anual a china excepción
notable esta entrevista a un eminente
biólogo chino en la televisión de hong
kong
no deberíamos hacer pruebas a gran
escala sistemáticamente si el gobierno
persiste con la política acero kobe
debido a algunos casos creo que la
economía de nuestro país sufrirá
ellos sin contar con la aparición de
omicron para las autoridades chinas la
extrema contagiosidad de la nueva
variante les da la razón
algunos países reaccionaron en cuanto a
algunos casos de omicron aparecieron
tomando medidas administrativas muy
estrictas con base en nuestra
experiencia a lo largo de los dos
últimos años el método chino es el
correcto y podría ser endurecido frente
a omicron un desafío para las empresas
extranjeras instaladas en china a las
que le cuesta contratar en el extranjero
las visas son concedidas a cuentagotas y
cada vez más expatriados abandonan el
país cortado del mundo tan solo en
shanghai cientos de ejecutivos esperan
sus visas desde hace meses pero ciertas
compañías aprovechan para concentrarse
en el mercado interno tal como esta
agencia de comunicaciones francés desde
el inicio de la crisis sanitaria en
febrero del 2020 tuvimos un crecimiento
de nuestra actividad en china
continental de unos 30 ó 40 también
tuvimos que hacer crecer la masa
salarial
más trabajar desde hace dos años todos
los nuevos empleados son chinos una
ventaja según su director el hecho de
tener más empleados locales nos aporta
más conocimiento más comprensión y más
saber hacer sobre el mercado local y la
cultura local y local las fronteras
podrían permanecer cerradas durante
mucho tiempo según las estimaciones más
optimistas china no debería reabrir
antes de un año